y en qué tono suceden las
manifestaciones conmemorativas de este
segundo aniversario
cuáles son los pedidos ciudadanos hoy
cuando ya está en marcha la
constituyente y cuando se espera
reparación por las víctimas del
estallido social
si no mira primero por supuesto
agradecer la invitación al espacio creo
que es muy importante que podamos
entablar este tipo de discusiones que se
pueda también saber a lo largo del mundo
lo que está sucediendo hoy en día en
chile con respecto a la pregunta en
particular considero que sin duda alguna
las demandas que ha puesto en pie la
ciudadanía el 18 octubre el 2019 son las
mismas que hoy en día están muy vigentes
no a pesar de tener más de 2 años no de
un proceso de estallido de un proceso de
intensas manifestaciones y tener en pie
hoy en día un proceso de cambio
constitucional y de alguna forma hemos
visto que los cambios no han quedado
tampoco han quedado bastante en tela de
juicio no se nos ha logrado lo que la
ciudadanía demandó en su momento sin
duda alguna el proceso constituyente es
fundamental se hace fundamental y
creemos que es necesario también para
seguir avanzando en las desigualdades
que enfrenta la sociedad chilena
actualmente y poder también avanzar
hacia campos profundos y hacia
transformaciones sociales profundas que
demandó la ciudadanía pero sin duda el
sistema de pensiones el sistema de salud
el acceso a la educación porque por
ejemplo y también las violaciones
sistemáticas masivas generalizadas en
los derechos humanos durante el
estallido social en chile han sido
demandas profundas las demandas de
verdad de justicia de reparación sin
duda alguna está muy presente y es
necesario también que podamos entablar
la discusión y el debate en dentro de
estas materias no bueno este aniversario
llega a poco más de un mes de las
elecciones cuáles son rápidamente las
expectativas del movimiento de protesta
para un próximo gobierno y para sus
legisladores
si es un proceso súper complejo ya nos
quedan 30 días para las elecciones y que
sin duda alguna el candidato de
ultraderecha se ha ido posicionando muy
bien en las encuestas y eso por supuesto
que genera mucho miedo mucho malestar y
mucha disconformidad con el proceso de
elecciones presidenciales yo creo que
aquí hay una cuestión súper fundamental
que tiene relación precisamente con que
hoy día la clase política no se ha
posicionado dentro de las demandas
sociales que tenemos actualmente y sin
duda esperamos que sean las y los
candidatos presidenciales quienes
recogen estas demandas porque es la
forma también institucional en que
podemos establecer la pero sin duda el
movimiento social la ciudadanía está
bastante disconforme también con el
proceso de elecciones presidenciales que
tenemos hoy en día y es importante
seguir avanzando en esas demandas y que
los candidatos y candidatas puedan
también hacer hacer y escuchar
precisamente lo que se está diciendo en
las calles muy fuertemente hoy sobre
todo 18 de octubre mire tomadas muy
rápidamente porque ya me estoy quedando
sin tiempo pero le quiero preguntar en
qué va la idea de la reforma policial a
partir de la violencia de 2019 y que
tanto siente su movimiento que
repercutió en américa latina' rápida por
favor sí sin duda alguna la reforma es
necesaria pero no necesitamos solamente
una reforma necesitamos la refundación
de la policía una refundación que tenga
como base la educación en derechos
humanos que ponga en el centro de los
derechos humanos para que de esa forma
no se siguen replicando es la única
forma en que la ciudadanía realmente va
a estar contenta con los procesos que
estamos enfrentando porque una reforma
no establecen precisamente los cambios
profundos que necesita esta policía
necesitamos una una refundación una
policía nueva una policía que respete
por supuesto los derechos humanos en
todos los territorios